there are
four papers or so there are more than
that but um you know it's early yet and
there
are four papers um that went
looking at whether or not you might
explain something about
um about the cover 19 pandemic
in terms of both likelihood of people
getting infected
and people do get infected whether or
not
you know how how sick they get if diet
has any effect on those things so
diet could mitigate um the severity of
your symptoms
um and might actually uh change whether
or not you get it at all and of course
at this point
um you know a even if we had the
resources
um this is not the sort of thing you're
going to be doing experimental work on
probably so it's purely correlational
and it's basically looking at you know
widespread like what kinds of diets
do people in uh you know different parts
of india eat
and in different parts of europe so the
two big studies that i've um that i've
spent some time with again
big correlational so suggestive but not
um not decisive by any means
that we're largely looking at
differences in um
in cobia 19 rates of
diagnosis and outcomes uh for those who
got sick
across europe and in india one of these
papers
um is called
oh no it it dropped me out that's not
nice of it at all there it is
okay so one of these papers is from july
of last year
by um i'm probably going to mispronounce
their name busque
busqueterol published in
allergy i think unless i've got that
wrong
um yeah allergy cabbage and fermented
vegetables from death rate heterogeneity
in countries to candidates for
mitigation strategies of severe covet
19.
interesting paper this one and i want to
just walk us through a little bit
of table 1 in here and then talk a bit
more broadly about some of the findings
from the other papers
so we have here this is you know again
this is they they've done a good job of
not pretending to quantify when they
really had no ability to
so this this kind of looks like you know
they have given one to four pluses here
to try to give an estimate
um but it's kind of like you know it's
kind of like what you did with your flow
chart like you know what
based on the available evidence this is
what i think is going on and so they've
said based on the available evidence
what do each of these risk factors
possible risk factors
um how are they going to explain
geographical differences
in um covert rates and outcomes at both
the individual level
and the country and region level and i'm
not going to spend any time really
talking about the distinction there um
but you know right and they
it's more or less organized excuse me
organized from you know most most
intensive effects
to least so contact with the sars kobe 2
infected individual
that is likely to do it right if if
anything is that's going to do it um
intensity of social contacts intensity
of occupational contacts
and confinement um with with such people
all of these things are high and this is
no news to anyone watching this right
um we moved down a little bit and
though and they've got diet and food and
long food chain supply and traditional
fermented food as the things that they
begin to talk about newly oh but before
we even get there vitamin d so something
you and i have been talking about for a
long time probably since march on this
on this podcast is um
other viruses seem to do more poorly
in humans not all of them some other
viruses seem to do more poorly in humans
the course of the disease is lessened
the severity of the symptoms are lower
when those people are able to get out in
the sun
so yes you can get vitamin d in a pill
form but for all of these things it is
almost certain that if you get it
in the form that you know it comes to
you in the form of food or in the case
of vitamin d in the form of sunlight
it's probably going to be more
efficacious and so they they revisit the
vitamin d question
um they find uh when they're just
mapping diet
onto um on to covet outcomes
that low prevalence in asia and africa
both suggest a role for diet and
specifically
they find in the next line here with
regard to food
uh that fermented food and this is this
shows up
twice here um that uh fermented food
is uh for for a number of reasons and
again i think at this point we don't
really have time to get into the
into the diet science too much um
may well be protective against
i may be both getting an extremity of
disease ideology in copen 19. so
specifically they talk about both raw
cabbage interestingly
ferments like sauerkraut and kimchi
yogurt
and so within europe they found i think
it was like turkey
and the balkans which have a lot of of
yogurt consumption
and then a lot of parts of germany which
have a lot of ferment consumption
having lower rates than the areas around
them which also have different cuisines
and then and this was this is one of
these things that you and i would refer
to as obvious in retrospect it had never
occurred to me before but as soon as i
saw this in
in this paper i thought yeah that that
makes sense
long food chain supply um
seems to be a long supply chain for your
food
yeah and i i just read that off here and
i realize that's not actually that's
that's not organized the right way um
long supply chain for your food
meaning uh that it took more steps and
probably came
from farther away from where it was
initially grown
to get to you is
is known from other research to be
associated with
metabolic disorders okay so that is
fascinating and obvious because you know
what does a long
um how do i order it the right way
uh supply supply chain for food tend to
mean
it's about food being highly processed
having some of its parts taken
out and then maybe added back in as if
those nutrients were always there so
it's pieces parts it's productionist
and it ends up being shelf stable maybe
freezer stable
it is it is very much not um
often representative of what the
original food was
and what we will see um and you know
maybe this is actually the moment to
switch
so zach if i can have my screen back um
from some of the other papers
uh is that specifically a plant-based
diet
high fiber diet high ferment diet
and and one more thing that i'm not
going to mention yet while we're just
talking about all this
all seem to be correlated with
negatively correlated with
obesity with metabolic syndrome
with long supply chain for food
and with positively correlated with
good outcomes for covid so you know if
you're looking for sort of diet advice
you know we we know that obesity
is one of the main comorbidities for
covet 19
and we don't get to talk about it
because we don't want to be fat shaming
which is
ridiculous pretending that something is
isn't good for you is not going to make
that thing go away we do not actually
live in a socially constructed
postmodernist universe
so well what's more we're denying people
a honest to goodness proper incentive to
get
uh to get in charge of their weight
um on the basis that yes okay uh obesity
is bad for you
it's especially bad for you in light of
something like covid and to not
talk about the protective uh
aspect of being at a reasonable weight
is
you know you're hurting the people that
you're trying to protect by not shaming
them so
it just makes it makes no sense it makes
no sense and um
we have i don't remember which paper
it's in talks about the inflammatory
properties of things like
red meat you know we're not vegetarians
we eat red meat so this this is not
about saying you need to adopt this diet
and you know we're perfect here we eat
vegetarians for breakfast
i don't i don't eat breakfast
red meat gluten largely in wheat
and alcohol are all understood to be
inflammatory
and background inflammation inflammation
seems to be contributing again to things
like metabolic syndrome
and weight gain and once you have weight
gain you have obesity so there's
you know there's at least one through
line one direct line
to um from some of these things to uh
okay maybe modifying your diet uh of you
know
you've always wanted to and here you go
like
this may actually help you stay safer
in an era of you know who knows emerging
zoonotic diseases
or diseases created um you know for us
by people interested in
doing research um
regardless they're out there this one's
out there and there will probably be
more
and how is it that we should be trying
to keep ourselves safe
one more thing um
actually no two more two a couple more
things
here's a quote from uh
a different busquet at all papers so
same lead author this one titled is diet
partly responsible for differences in
covenanting death rates between within
countries
uh they say uh foods with potent
antioxidant are anti-ace activity like
uncooked or fermented cabbage are
largely consumed in low death rate
european countries
korea and taiwan and might be considered
in the low prevalence of deaths
again correlational there's no ability
to establish a causal relationship here
and then just to go back to the supply
chain
issue quote the increasing availability
of foods from big retail is a
revolutionary event that has impacted
crops
favoring those that have the best ratio
of effectiveness over cost of production
and health at a population size level in
particular such a change in food
availability has altered elementary
habits
promoting sugar enriched vitamin d
populated foods
and has become one of the causes of the
obesity epidemic especially among
adolescents
these foods come from centralized farms
and selected areas of the world that are
distributed around the planet
elongating the supply chain of food the
impact of long supply chain of food on
health is measurable by an increase in
metabolic syndrome
and insulin resistance um so the one
more thing
uh that we haven't mentioned yet that
these papers uh
suggest uh might might be implicated as
a useful
dietary tool uh to avoid
or mitigate the impacts of covid is
intermittent fasting
interestingly uh so a different paper
richard all diet gut microbiota and kova
19
says intermittent fasting which includes
alternate day fasting or time restricted
feeding
has been reported to favorably influence
the gut microbiota by increasing the
abundance of beneficial acromensia
mucinophila and bacteroides fragilis in
fact various animal trials and some
human intervention studies have clearly
demonstrated health benefits associated
with iaf in people with underlying
diabetes
obesity and cardiovascular ailments
and these authors if memory serves
specifically find
pockets demographic pockets of people
who were effectively forced into
intermittent fasting because they didn't
have enough
food due to the epidemic due to the
pandemic
who had better outcomes when they did
end up
getting the disease so again
correlational we can't know for sure
but um super interesting and suggestive
and for those who
have never heard of intermittent fasting
before you know it can be anything from
you eat only for eight hours a day and
not at all from for 16
to you don't eat anything for two days a
week you know lots of different
options all right well that is
uh quite consistent with what what we've
been seeing
so the the upshot is diet especially
short
uh supply chain fermented foods
go outside get your vitamin d uh make
vitamin d while the sun shines as they
never say that's right
um they don't say it and what that also
means is if you're outside and you're
not around anyone else
get the sun on your face you don't need
to be wearing a mask if you're outside
not around anyone else
and um it's it's been shocking to us
from the beginning that um
outside areas were shut down and it's
one thing if you really can't control
the density and people are crowded
really close to one another but
so far so far even these new variants
don't seem to be spreading outside